Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the slow-mo guys.
I'm cringing slightly because Dan
has a Katana sword at my throat level.
I actually use this to shave.
Even just joking about that
makes me cringe,
Come on.
because I know how
immensely sharp that is.
You can see it.
You can see the point just
disappear into nothingness.
Yeah.
We're gonna slice up some water bottles.
You always see those compilations
of very satisfying things,
especially in GIF form.
And one of them is just
slicing through bottles
with a Katana.
Yeah I mean I'm sure this is sharp enough,
but it depends on my skill,
whether I can actually get
all through those bottles.
How would you rate your
skills as a swordsman?
Not the best.
I mean you don't really
learn it in the army.
I guess, unless you're, I don't know,
in the cavalry or an officer or something.
Yeah, and use your Katana sword,
hop on the horse.
Yeah yeah, off you go.
All right let's get to the
slicing and the dicing.
Filming this on the Phantom Flex4K,
thousand frames a second,
I've got a long trigger
cable so I can be over there,
just in case Dan lets go of the sword,
or it's cheap and it just
flies straight out of the hill.
Who knows.
Do you want goggles or anything?
What, in case I get a
sword in the eye somehow?
Oh I don't know.
Whoopsie.
Just looking out for you B.
Cheers B.
All right.
How many do you think I'll get through
with my first swing?
Because I've never done this before.
I think you'll go like
and get like six.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Ready?
You're absolutely right.
I got through like four and messed it up.
I'm so bad at this.
I just saw water go all over the Phantom.
Oh no.
Probably should move it back a bit.
Yeah.
Your face.
I'm just concentrating too much.
It got deflected so perfectly,
that it just caught this one bottle here,
right on the lid,
and like, made a little leaky hole.
You couldn't have done that
if you tried.
Imagine that,
"Open this bottle for me,"
Za!
Thank you.
All right, we're reducing the amount to
a measly 10.
Measly 10.
It's not the blades fault,
because it's just going
straight through them.
You saw on that last shot.
I think what's happening is,
as your blade hits at this angle,
it just drives that angle.
Like, whatever slight angle you have
is like amplified when you go through.
It has to be pitch perfect
on where it hits and how it hits
to go through all of them.
Yeah.
If I'm even slightly off on the angle,
it's just gone.
It's very difficult.
Flipping heck.
Goodness me.
Got no idea how many I got through there.
I think it was about seven.
Seven?
That's my record so far.
That's not bad.
Cheers.
Ready to go B.
Ready to go.
Right, I'm gonna hold
the sword at a slightly,
like, downwards angle,
so that hopefully when I swing,
it's gonna just stay level
as opposed to going up.
All right B.
Okay?
Yeah.
You ready?
This feels weird,
holding it like that but,
here we go.
Way better.
I think you've found your calling there.
Flip!
It went through like butter.
They're all like very similar height too.
Look, this just popped off.
There was water held in there.
Did you see that?
So wait.
It was just holding water
and it just went "oof".
So wait, you chopped that,
and it fell and landed
with water inside?
With water in it, yeah.
How did you get such a perfect seal?
I didn't even realize it had water in it
because I picked it up
and I was just like,
"Whoa!"
So you angled it slightly down.
Yeah, I angled it down.
It just doesn't fit
naturally in the hands.
It sort of fits slightly wrong.
Oh my Lord!
Every bottle still has water in the top.
That was perfect.
I didn't knock anything at all.
It just went straight through.
Some of the bottles barely noticed, look.
This one landed with water inside it.
It looks like the bottle's
been somehow trapped
in the table.
It's like Willy Wonka's bottle.
It's been like, X-Men-ed into the table.
Before we move onto colored ones Daniel.
Yeah.
Now that you've discovered
your true sorting method.
My calling in life.
Why don't we just put the
rest of the bottles up,
and see how many you
can get through, yeah?
Okay, so last time it was 10,
and this time I'm gonna
cover the entire table
and see what happens.
And pretty much to see if it's a fluke.
16, there's an extra six.
Little bit more pressure.
I've also switched the camera now to 4K,
because I just wanna see the
lovely resolution on this one.
Be a little bit faster,
but, oh the pixels.
No pressure then.
No pressure.
Where do I even aim?
Oh God, where do I aim?
It's just too much.
Looks like it went up again.
Yeah.
It looks like you got one more than
last time.
Oh I did, yeah.
It was just a fluke maybe.
It was a fluke.
God.
Ah.
What?
Come over here.
What is it?
So I think I know what happened here.
You can see where you went wrong.
Go on.
Oh no!
I hit the table.
You took a chunk
of the table out.
I was like, "I'm sure
that would work again."
It's because right, go back, rewind it.
This is the problem.
I was looking at that, the last bottle,
because I was like,
"Well, that's where I've got to swing to."
It was just too many to concentrate on.
To be fair, the fact
that you hit the table
and then hit 11 bottles,
that's impressive to me.
I feel like the technique
definitely worked though.
Yeah.
It's just, I hit the table first.
Oh man.
Where's this bit of missing table.
Whoa!
I just sliced it clean off.
Look at it.
That's our
favorite table Dan.
No, the janky table has
The jankiest table.
taken a hit.
Should we try and glue
it back together again?
Well, if we can find the little...
chunk.
Oh.
Where'd it damn go?
Here it is.
Oh yeah.
Let's get that back.
Oh. There we go.
I can't believe I hit the table first.
What a mug.
Okay, the colors are ready.
Yeah.
Better prepare for a
sticky mess on this one.
Oh yeah.
We'll do it twice, I'll go wide and tight.
Slower on the closeup.
Okay.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What a colorful, sticky, fizzy mess.
Oh, I just put this lens on too.
Oh no, has it got caked.
Caked, the house is caked.
Oh, the house is covered in red juice.
Definitely went up again then?
How can you tell?
No idea.
I wanted to just leave them
completely where they were,
but, because of the pop they
kind of bang and explode.
Yeah.
So they just go everywhere.
We'll get a closer up on now.
Yeah.
Yes, nailed it.
Nailed it.
Felt so much better.
Whoa!
Oh!
Sorry B.
Damn it.
Oh!
Geez!
That's how you get ants.
Every video that goes by,
the resale value of this place goes down.
It's horrendous.
It's like tainting a place.
You always know the guy
that just taints it.
It's cool how the empty space clouds up,
as they are breached.
It's amazing how much brighter
it gets after the hit.
Like, this is quite a dark image.
Yeah.
You can see on the histogram,
as soon as it starts happening,
all the light goes up.
Oh wow, yeah.
That's how many brighter pixels there are.
That's cool.
Is it because the water's
reflecting the light?
Is that what's going on?
What it is, is that the fizz
is just making the liquid
whiter than it was before.
Oh.
And also, you've got the sun glistening
through it once in the air.
My little pan there.
Yeah, nice, strong.
Very strong.
I figured most of the action
was gonna go to the right,
so, I'll wait for you to be done,
and then go, "Whoop."
Did you make the noise as well?
I may have done.
Can't believe I actually managed
to get through all those bottles,
and it was so much easier
when I angled it right.
It just went through all of them,
it just felt like butter, it was nothing.
My favorite shot is just the
shard of table flying away.
All right, I messed that one up, yeah.
It was just too hard,
too many bottles there.
Very satisfying footage.
Very satisfying.
Very cool.
I can see that perfect one
being turned into a GIF
of just like, "Oh it's nice to look at,
and I don't know why."
Yeah.
And then someone's gonna end it
just before it goes through the last one.
Unsatisfying.
Yeah, that'll be so annoying.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on twitter.
You can subscribe to this channel.
We also have a second channel.
We do.
BTS and all that.
And we will hopefully see
you in the next video,
because this is what
we do on this channel.
We continually make slow-mo videos
until the end of time.
Which, for our videos,
Which, for these cameras,
is really far away.
Is forever. Yeah.